okay geometry lesson number one this is
like geometry 101 you want to understand
some basic terms and how to write the
different lines points planes and there
were going to jump into some typical
questions that you experience in this
first geometry lesson so let's go over
the terms first so we're gonna work with
undefined terms these are terms that are
basically accepted as true if we don't
have to prove anything we just accept it
the first thing is a point and a point
basically we represent in geometry as a
dot and it's basically infinitesimally
small but it just locates a point in
space right and so what we do is we just
label it with a capital letter like a or
you can have another point over here B
and so you would just say if you're
identifying the point you would just say
point A or if you were saying point B
point B like that okay now when we talk
about a line you know from algebra one
you know a line it goes in you know two
directions and it keeps going forever
and ever right it's a set of points and
we know it looks something like this but
when you identify a line you want to use
two points that are on the line like say
for example if you have a point x and y
that are on the line the way you write
it the notation it's kind of like a
pictograph you know our picture like
hieroglyphics you would draw x and y and
you would draw actually like that line
symbol above x and y to indicate that
it's a line that it keeps going in both
directions or you could say Y X it
doesn't matter the order now one thing I
want to point out is that a point is
actually zero dimensional okay so it's
like no dimension whereas a line is 1d
or one dimensional when we get to a
plane now a plane is like a flat surface
kind of like the floor or like a wall or
the ceiling right that's 2-dimensional
and we generally draw it like a
rectangle or a parallelogram to kind of
show that you know that it's a flat
surface but you have to kind of realize
that it keeps going you know in forever
and ever like on this flat surface at
that level but when you label a plane
you can either use like a capital letter
like it'll indicate in like the one of
the corners of the plane so for example
I could call this plane M
or what you can do is you can pick three
points that are not in a straight line
say for example like if this is a B and
C I could write this as plain ABC that's
another way to do it but you want to
make sure that they're not in a straight
line now why why do you not want them to
be in a straight line well if they're in
a straight line like this there is more
than one plane or more than one flat
surface that could go through those
three points so that's why when you draw
three non collinear points meaning that
they're not in a straight line there's
only one plane or one flat surface that
goes through those three points so the
plane remember is 2-dimensional and then
we get to space which is what we think
of as you know three dimensional and
we'll talk about that a little bit later
so we have 0 D 1 D 2 D 3 D now when we
move over here segments a segment is
like a portion of a line it has
basically a beginning and an end right
we call these two points where it starts
and finishes it as endpoints and so when
you write your segment you would pick
these two endpoints x and y and you just
put like a bar above them so that
represents a segment now you can also
write it the other way Y acts with that
bar above it to indicate that it's a
segment and not align with the line
symbol above it with array you think of
a ray is like a ray of sunshine right
it's like there's a photon at the Sun
and it's going out from the Sun towards
the Earth it just goes one direction it
has an endpoint we call this an endpoint
but you can think of as like a starting
point and it just goes that one
direction so this is what we would call
ray CD and when you draw the symbol for
Ray you always want to draw it to the
right so for example with this ray here
notice how the Ray is actually going to
the left look at the way we're going to
write this you're gonna write this as e
f and see how the arrow is pointing like
towards F it's starting at E right and
it's going towards F and it keeps going
so that's Ray EF so that's just the
convention that it's always drawn
pointing to the right even if the Ray is
pointing to the left and then opposite
rays what does that mean opposite rays
well it means that they're going a
hundred and eighty degrees opposite one
another and together they form a line
but the key is you want them to have the
same starting point which remember these
starting points are called end points
and so you would write the two opposite
rays here is our
TC it starts at iron goes towards T and
R s so it starts at R and it goes
towards s and keeps going so together it
forms line s T or R T or TS you just
need two points on the line to to write
the line now as far as intersection goes
when we talk about intersection we're
talking about what points to the objects
have in common or you think of
intersection you probably think of like
where do the two objects cross so if you
have two lines they're always gonna
cross at a point okay like that unless
they're parallel or skew and we'll get
into that later but over here when you
have two planes these are like two flat
surfaces where they cross is actually at
a line so if lines intersect across at a
point if planes intersect they're gonna
cross at a line let me erase the
whiteboard I've got some specific
questions that you're going to encounter
and we'll work through those next okay
pause the video if you want and see if
you can answer these questions and we're
going to go through them together here
so what I want you to do is name all
these quantities here's will name a
point in this diagram here so what do
you think so I think there's a lot of
answers here there's more than one
correct answer but for example we could
just say T that's a point or we could
say ass or we could say W any of those
would be correct
you only have to list one for number two
you want to name a line so what do you
think a good one for a line would be
well there's a lot of options here I'm
gonna pick maybe like this line right
here W X and I'm going to put the line
symbol above it to indicate that it's a
line that's very important it doesn't
matter the order of the points the
letters here but you definitely want to
put the line symbol above it to indicate
that's a line for a segment what do you
think would be a good example of a
segment well how about if we do from s
to X so that would be a sax we'll just
put a bar above it now your teacher is
going to be very particular about this
notation so you want to make sure you
really get a good grasp of this don't be
too sloppy with it for number four array
okay what do you think a good example of
array would be I'm gonna say ray XR x
are so that means it's starting at X is
going towards our and it keeps going
notice how that symbol is going to the
right even though the ray is going
downward right for number five a pair of
opposite rays now a lot of times when
you're doing these problems if you look
at the words very carefully it'll tell
you what it is like pair that means like
a pair of shoes like two right opposite
right so we're thinking 180 degrees
opposite rays so a pair of opposite
raise a good example would be something
like access an X R so we could say X
going towards s and keeps going X going
towards our and keeps going but they
have that same end point end point you
think it was a starting point but
they're going 180 degrees opposite
forming a line what you don't want by
the way is you don't want this situation
where it's like see how these have like
different end points like you don't want
them to be alike I'll just see if I can
draw like this you wouldn't want this to
be let's say this is ABC you wouldn't
want to do ray AC in ray ba because then
they don't have the same starting point
you want it to have the same starting
point and then from there go 180 degrees
opposite for number six name a plane
remember a plane's a flat surface we
could say plane a that would be one
option right so plane a or you could
pick three points that are not in the
same flat surface so we could say like x
SW so I could say plane x SW you just
use three points you want to do four or
five six just pick three points that are
not in a straight line
that defines a plane and then another
name for plane a that's kind of funny we
just did that one x SW but we could do
let's say x RW that's this flat surface
as well so that's another option plane x
r w for number 8 3 : ear points now we
didn't talk about this too much in yet
but when you see the word Co that means
same and you see the word linear that
means like line so we're looking for
three points that are on the same line
so an example here would be a sax in our
so s X and are now three completer
points so three points that are in the
same plane meaning
same flat surface so we could do for
example TW and XR in this flat plane B
right so let's do X W and T points that
is not collinear with line W X so here's
line W X a point that's not on that line
how about point T that would work a
point that's not coplanar with plane be
so plane B is this flat surface right
here if we want a point it's not in that
same plane we could pick R or we could
pick s so I'll just say R and then we
want to find the intersection of line L
and M now we didn't talk about this
earlier we were talking about lines but
another way that they sometimes label
lines is with like a little cursive
letter at the end of the line so you can
call this like line L like that or you
could say a line M okay for this line
but the intersection of line L and M
where do they cross at point X remember
two lines when they cross it cross at a
point and then what's an intersection of
plane a and plane B so this flat surface
and this flat surface where do they
cross or intersect you can see they're
intersecting right at this line we could
say line m or we could say line X W
either of those would work so I hope
this helped you understand Luud about
the notation and an introduction into
geometry if you want to see more
geometry videos I've got a ton of them
on my mario's math tutor YouTube channel
you can check out the playlist that I'm
going to put right there for you you can
use it as you're going through your
class if you're trying to review
geometry there's a lot of good
information there I'll see over in those
videos